first up oh this guy I used to laugh my
ass at him on Saturday Night Live and
politically incorrect what he was on it
any went on to other things
that's right he's a senator Al Franken
is over
Gary Jonah there Gary Johnson did not
know the name of the President of Mexico
when he was the governor of New Mexico
right yeah it's like Jerry Brown the
Governor of California not knowing the
city where people go to gamble Las Vegas
okay I'm sorry
anyway al it is so good to see you
telling jokes again him and you haven't
been on the show in a very long time as
you had done for a very good reason you
had to take a humor hiatus you were
known as it I don't has ever been a
comedian right elected to the Senate no
right dude you were breaking new ground
and you had to prove to people yes you
were serious before you could go back to
being funny but now you can go back to
be funny cuz you not being funny
it's like Trump not being an [ __ ] it
just it's sleep thank you it's that is
so gosh that's the nicest thing anyone's
said to me it's it's your essence well
you know I I really enjoy this job and
really enjoy making a difference and in
my 2008 election which was very close
what they used against me was stuff I
had said in comedy and they put it
through a machine called the D humor
Iser and so robbed it of all its content
et cetera a D humor Iser and then you
know I came to the Senate and I wanted
to make sure that people Minnesota
especially but also my colleagues in the
Senate knew that I was there to be a
workhorse and not a show horse and in
many ways I used Hillary as a model not
not that she had been know did that
funny she was funny but not that funny
but that she had come to the same issue
she had some of the same issues that
Republican colleagues or maybe
suspicious of her that Democratic
colleagues might thought that she was
going to
take their camera time but she did was
she was a workhorse and I had the same
thing because I had come from comm right
about the camera time and the
Republicans I had used a lot of my
career to keep scorn and ridicule on
Republicans so but but my Republican
colleagues soon learned that I was I was
there at the hearings I was prepared I
was there early I stayed late I knew my
stuff and and they also got with no man
time Marco Rubio well you showed up and
you knew [ __ ] okay but they actually got
to know me and sit and they got to know
like oh I see he was a convenient cuz
he's funny
right and I laugh a lot right so a lot
of across party lines when when we can
find common ground and I stand my ground
when I have to right and you do it well
and and as speaking of heaping scorn you
know 2003 you had your book lying liars
and the lies they tell lies and lying
liars who tell them yeah okay um but and
you know the great most and
put the you know and put the focus where
it should be on the lies and the liars
but I mean can you imagine where we've
come with lying now
I mean someone like Donald Trump has
broken ground in a way that science
never thought we I mean he lies
sometimes within the same sentence he
lies about lying if he could have thing
is when I did that it was President Bush
w and it was kind of quaint to point out
that things were lies or distortions and
it's just changed we're in a post trump
era in terms of line and and politicians
don't seem to pay a penalty for
insulting your intelligence with lies
lying about lying aligned for the sake
of line you don't pay any price for that
in fact it's just the opposite we seem
to be a very Pro lysis ayah T right now
right and well if people don't know
anything well many of the supporters say
when people don't know anything
politicians can say anything but they
also think checking I think they like it
because it they it takes the reality
that they think is boring the boring
political reality and makes it fun it's
like taking if I get a movie out of a
true story but mostly basing it you know
and and so yeah so I think the public
has become decidedly Pro lie yeah I mean
it's it must be very hard to you mention
working across there must be very hard
in that atmosphere and we have seen I
mean just in the time you've been there
they won't vote on the Supreme Court
justice I mean something like
unprecedented unprecedented things like
Zika virus something like that used to
be very nonpartisan there's a killer
mosquito let's do something about it
right can't vote on that is there is
there any hope to ending this kind of
stalemate yes I like to think there is
first of all I'm hope that Hillary wins
sorry
I should put that up you out yeah I'm
sorry too they killed time with the
applause I'm sorry uh but and and then I
hope we have a Democratic Senate don't
you know I know you like that but but
here's the thing and then I think we get
a new Supreme Court justice and citizens
united was decided 5-4 and I would like
to think that we can reverse that and
this is what's been so pernicious about
citizens united is that I see a lot of
my Republican colleagues who fear
getting primary on the right and for
example on climate change which you care
a tremendous about and I do they will
not acknowledge the existence of climate
change and it's man-made because they're
afraid that in their state they can only
lose on the right and that the Koch
brothers can dump immediately ten
million dollars on them to be primary by
someone whose profile fuels so if
citizens united goes away a lot of that
fear goes away I think from my
Republican colleagues now last time I
say you I mentioned this in private
I'm gonna ask you again I said I have an
idea about citizens united because
Congress people spent in an ordinate of
time begging for money what if they made
a law that said okay we can't overturn
that you can get money but the
politician themselves can't do it if
somebody in your office has to do it
you can never legally get on the phone
with someone wouldn't that be a good law
wouldn't they all vote for it because
they don't really want to do it well
actually we can't literally ask for the
citizen United my that's not the money
we asked for but you've been hours and
hours asking for money you've done it
with me
what if it was a eunuch you want to give
me Citizens United money but okay the
distinction is any campaign fine where I
would like to see public financing of
campaigns me too
but short of that that I would like to
see oh and I did you're right I spend an
awful lot of time it what happens is
when I call you for money if we just end
up talking and if you're just just a big
waste of well you're not a waste of time
you'd give me money but you see
Singam